IN THIS HOSPITAL BEHIND ME
RECOVERING.
WILL: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
KRISTIN.
AFTER A DAY OF A FAIR AMOUNT OF
CONFUSION, A HEAVY DOSE OF
SPECULATION IT REMAINS BEST TO
GO TO THE SOURCE.
WE GOT IT DIRECTLY FROM THE
PRESIDENT LAST NIGHT AND OUR
NEXT GUEST HAS PHONE THE MAN FOR
DECADES AND HE SPOKE TO THE
PRESIDENT YESTERDAY.
RUDY GIULIANI, THE PRESIDENT’S
ATTORNEY, FORMER NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR, THE HOST OF THE
RUDY GIULIANI COMMON SENSE
PODCAST.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
WE KNOW YOU SPOKE TO THE
PRESIDENT YESTERDAY ON THE
PHONE.
HOW WAS FEELING, HOW DID HE
SOUND?
>> WELL I MEAN ON THE PHONE HE
SOUNDED LIKE HIMSELF COMPLETELY.
I MEAN WE HAD ABOUT 35, 40
MINUTE CONVERSATION.
SOME OF IT ABOUT HIS HEALTH, I
WAS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HIM.
I WAS HAPPY TO HEAR HIS VOICE,
SOUNDING EXACTLY THE SAME I’VE
KNOWN FOR 30 YEARS.
AFTER WE TALKED ABOUT HIS
HEALTH, WE STARTED TO TALK ABOUT
POLITICS AND HE GAVE ME A LOT OF
NOTES TO GIVE TO THE CAMPAIGN
WHAT THEY SHOULD DO, HOW THEY
SHOULD DO IT.
EVEN WROTE OUT A KIND OF A
SPEECH.
I HAD TO KIND OF GET HIM OFF THE
PHONE SO HE WENT BACK AND RESTED
AND HE DID SAY THAT HE WOULD
LOVE TO GET OUT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
HE FEELS LIKE HE COULD GO OUT
NOW.
HE SAID HE FELT PRETTY BAD THE
FIRST DAY BUT NOW HE FEELS, FOR
THE LAST 24 HOURS, THAT WAS
3:00 YESTERDAY, HE FELT
PERFECTLY FINE.
NO FEVER.
A LITTLE TIRED BUT NOT VERY
TIRED.
FOR HIM TO BE A LITTLE TIRED IS
NOTHING.
SO I FORESEE, I HAD SEVERAL
FRIENDS THAT HAVE BEEN THROUGH
THIS, SOME MUCH WORSE, THEY HAVE
GOTTEN THROUGH, THEY’RE FINE
NOW, HE IS PROBABLY THE
STRONGEST AND HEALTHIEST GUY I
KNOW ANYWHERE NEAR HIS AGE.
JEDEDIAH: WELL THAT IS VERY GOOD
NEWS TO HEAR, RUDY.
ANOTHER QUESTION ON EVERYONE’S
MIND, HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
WE KNOW YOU WERE IN THE DEBATE
PREP ROOM.
CHRIS CHRISTIE WAS IN THE ROOM
AS WELL.
WE KNOW HE HAS TESTED POSITIVE
AND CHECKED HIMSELF INTO A
HOSPITAL AS A CAUTIOUS MEASURE
BUT ARE YOU OKAY?
HAVE YOU BEEN TESTED?
>> YEAH, I HAVE BEEN TESTED.
I WAS TESTED TWO DAYS AGO.
I WILL BE TESTED PROBABLY
TOMORROW.
I HAVE NO SYMPTOMS.
CHRIS WAS ON MY RIGHT AND
KELLYANNE ON MY LEFT, FOUR
HOURS, TWO DIFFERENT DAYS.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN FRONT OF ME
WHEN WE WERE DOING IT.
I WAS ON THE AIRPLANE WITH HIM.
I SAW HIM AGAIN ON WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON.
LAST TIME I SAW HIM WAS
WEDNESDAY ABOUT 2:15 BEFORE HE
WAS TAKING OFF FOR THE RALLY.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, LIKE JOE
SAID BEFORE, YOU COULD HAVE
KNOCKED ME DOWN WHEN I HEARD HE
HAD COVID ON FRIDAY MORNING.
HE LOOKED, HE LOOKED PERFECT.
HE LOOKED REALLY GOOD.
SO THESE THINGS ARE STRANGE.
HOW CAN YOU EXPLAIN IT?
CHRIS HERE, KELLYANNE THERE.
THEY BOTH HAVE IT AND, RIGHT NOW
I DON’T.
JUST DON’T KNOW.
I THINK, THE THING THE PRESIDENT
I THINK WANTS PEOPLE TO KNOW IS,
WE HAVE TO FACE UP TO THIS
ILLNESS.
HE COULD HAVE CHOSEN TO GO HIDE
SOMEWHERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE FOR
FIVE MONTHS, PARTICULARLY SINCE
THIS, PRETTY NICE AND YOU CAN
COMMUNICATE FROM THERE.
HE SAID I COULDN’T DO THAT I HAD
TO CAUTIOUSLY START TO GO OUT
AND LEAD THE WAY BACK.
IF I DIDN’T LEAD, WHO WAS GOING
TO LEAD?
IF I STAYED HOLED UP THERE, THE
WHOLE ECONOMY WOULD STAY HOLED
UP.
I REALLY RELATE TO THAT.
THAT IS THE WAY I FELT ON
SEPTEMBER 11th.
I FELT I HAD TO GET OUT IN
FRONT.
I HAD TO LEAD.
THE CITY WOULD TAKE A LITTLE
WHILE TO COME BACK.
MAYBE I WAS TAKING A RISK TO GET
HIM TO COME OUT SO FAST, WORK
DOWN THERE.
LIFE HAS TO GO ON.
WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH RISK.
WE HAVE TO TEACH OUR CHILDREN
THAT.
THERE IS, I DIDN’T GET COVID BUT
GOD FORBID SOMETHING ELSE COULD
HAPPEN TO ME IN 20 MINUTES.
YOU DON’T STOP LIVING.
COVID NOW IS TREATABLE.
COVID AT A MORTALITY, FATALITY
RATE WHICH IS, WITHIN THE NORM
FOR A SERIOUS ILLNESS.
SO IT IS NO LONGER WHAT IT WAS
FOUR OR FIVE MONTHS AGO.
IF WE ACT LIKE FOUR OR FIVE
MONTHS AGO WE’RE ALL HIDING
BEHIND CHAIRS AND HAVE BIG MASKS
ON ALL THE TIME, GOSH OUR
ECONOMY WILL NEVER GET GOING.
SO WEAR A MASK.
CLEANSE YOUR HANDS, BE CAREFUL
BUT DON’T BE PARALYZED, PLEASE,
PLEASE.
OUR ECONOMY HAS TO COME BACK,
FOR THE GOOD OF OUR CHILDREN WE
GET THE ECONOMY BACK.
WHICH ASSERT OURSELVES AS THE
MOST POWERFUL NATION ON EARTH.
BECAUSE IF WE DON’T, WHO YOU
KNOW WHO WILL, CHINA.
THEY ATTACKED US.
I HOED THEM RESPONSIBLE, I HOLD
THEM RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED TO MY PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY, DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY
AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
PETE: VERY IMPORTANT POINT,
MR. MAYOR.
GREAT POINT.
YOU SAID YOU HAD TO KICK THE
PRESIDENT OFF THE PHONE AFTER
ABOUT 40 MINUTES.
SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT.
GOOD INFORMATION.
YOU MENTIONED LEADING AFTER
9/11, UNPRECECEDENTED TIME AND T
PRESIDENT IS CHANNELING THAT.
WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE TO HIM
HAVING SPOKEN TO HIM ABOUT THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS GOING
FORWARD?
WHAT ACTIONS SHOULD HE BE TAKING
AT THIS MOMENT, DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, IT IS A LITTLE LIKE A
BASEBALL PLAYER.
I LOVE BASEBALL PLAYERS.
SOMETIMES THEY GET INJURIES,
COME BACK TOO FAST, PETE, THEN
FOOTBALL PLAYERS GET REALLY
INJURED.
THIS WILL NOT BE LONG.
TALKING THREE TO SEVEN DAYS FOR
A RECOVERY.
I SAID LISTEN TO THE DOCTOR.
THIS IS THE CHANCE FOR US, ALL
OF US WHO HE HAS CARRIED 3 1/2
FOUR YEARS.
WE WATCHED THIS MAN, THOSE OF US
LOVE HIM AND CHOIR FOR HIM,
MAKES YOU CRY WHAT THEY HAVE
TRIED TO DO.
EVERY SINGLE DAY FROM THE DAY HE
STARTED UNTIL NOW.
LAST WEEK NANCY PELOSI WANTED TO
IMPEACH HIM BECAUSE HE NOMINATED
JUDGE BARRETT.
I IMPEACH HIM OVER JUDGE
BARRETT?
SOME OF THE OTHERS WERE JUST AS
STUPID.
THEY HAVE TORTURED THIS MAN, HE
HAS ACCOMPLISHED MORE THAN ANY
PRESIDENT I CAN REMEMBER.
MAYBE HE IS ENTITLED TO A LITTLE
REST.
I SAID TO HIM.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS.
THEY’RE CALLING ME.
THEY WANT TO HELP YOU.
WE CAN’T CAMPAIGN AS WELL AS YOU
CAN, BUT WE CAN CAMPAIGN.
I THINK SOMETHING IS SPARKED IN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
LIKE A FRIEND YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF OR YOU, NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF, YOU TAKE FOR GRANTED.
HE IS THE FRIEND WE’VE BEEN
TAKING FOR GRANTED.
WE’VE HE HAS BEEN CARRYING US.
NOW TIME TO CARRY HIM.
YOU WILL SEE THE CAMPAIGN FAN
OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
PROBABLY WILL HAVE MORE PEOPLE
THAN BEFORE.
WE HAVE MORE VOLUNTEERS THE LAST
TWO DAYS, THAN MAYBE THE FIRST
DAY HE ANNOUNCED.
WILL: RUDY AS WAS MENTIONED THE
BEGINNING OF THE PRESIDENT, YOU
WERE INVOLVED WITH DEBATE PREP.
YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND THE DEBATE
PREP.
THE NEXT ONE SCHEDULED IS THE
VICE-PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE.
KAMALA HARRIS IS OUT AHEAD OF
HER DEBATE.
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY.
GET ADVICE HOW MIKE PENCE WILL
PREPARE FOR THE DEBATE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> SURE.
>> LET’S PUT OUR SHOULDERS TO
THE WHEEL.
DO THE WORK TO NECESSARILY TO
FIGHT FOR OUR IDEALS AND OUR
VALUES, IN THIS CASE WHAT THEY
FOUGHT FOR SO MANY YEARS AGO
WHICH IS FOR FREEDOM AND TO HOLD
OUR COUNTRY ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
IDEALS WE SAY WE HOLD DEAR.
SO IT IS GREAT TO BE HERE.
I’M REALLY HONORED TO BE HERE.
I WILL BE HERE FOR THE NEXT FEW
DAYS PREPARING FOR THE DEBATE.
I WANT TO THANK THE PEOPLE OF
UTAH FOR BEING WELCOMING IN A
WARM WAY.
WILL: RUDY, THIS DEBATE BETWEEN
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE AND CALM
KAMALA HARRIS HAS TO BE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM ONE THAT TOOK
PLACE A WEEK AGO.
WHAT WILL YOU SEE GOING FORWARD.
WHAT AD VICAR WOULD YOU GIVE?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS A GREAT
DEBATER.
HE IS VERY, VERY STRONG SPEAKER.
HE IS REALLY SMART.
OBVIOUSLY HE WILL POINT OUT WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ACCOMPLISHED AND ALSO I THINK
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE ARE HAVING A
RECOVERY.
WE’RE HAVING A RECOVERY BETTER
THAN ANYBODY EXPECTED.
I MEAN THE GUY WHO GAVE US THE
BEST ECONOMY POSSIBLE IS GIVING
US A RECOVERY FIVE TIMES FASTER
THAN ALL THE EXPERTS PREDICTED T
WOULD BE TRAGIC TO TRY TO
INTERRUPT THAT WITH SOMETHING
LIKE KAMALA HARRIS WHO WANTS TO
HAVE, SHE IS NOT GOING TO HAVE
ANY PROBLEM WITH THAT WHOLE
GREEN THING THERE.
SHE WILL HAVE NO PROBLEM AT ALL.
SHE IS BIG IN FAVOR OF IT.
SHE WANTS TO RAISE TAXES TO 60,
70%.
SHY ENDORSES THE ENTIRE
SOCIALIST PROGRAM.
SHE IS ONE OF THE AUTHORS OF IT.
SO I MEAN, HE HAS GOT TO POINT
OUT WHO SHE IS.
SHE IS A VERY, VERY MASSIVE
SPENDING SOCIALIST AND THEN HER
RECORD DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
I WOULD LOVE TO TAKE THAT APART.
I WAS A U.S. ATTORNEY.
SHE IS ONE OF THE ONES I
CONSIDER MORE DISGRACEFUL U.S.
ATTORNEY.
SHE PUT LITTLE PEOPLE IN JAIL
AND LET BIG PEOPLE GO.
1500 MARIJUANA SMOKERS AND BIG
GANGSTERS AND WENT FREE, BECAUSE
SHE COULDN’T CONVICT ANYBODY.
SHE WENT AFTER THE LITTLE PEOPLE
TO GET STATISTICS.
I HAVE CAN PICK OUT IN A SECOND.
CERTAIN NUMBER OF PROSECUTORS
ARE LIKE THAT.
TOO AMBITIOUS AND NOT ETHICAL.
SHE HAS TO POINT OUT WHO SHE IS.
THIS IS A WOLF IN SHEEP’S
CLOTHING.
THIS IS A TRUE SOCIALIST AND
GIVEN THE FACT THAT JOE BIDEN
DOESN’T SEEM TO BE AS KIND AS I
CAN SAY IT, THAT SHARP AND GETS
PUSHED A LITTLE, HIS POSITIONS
CHANGE ALL THE TIME.
WE DON’T KNOW WHERE HIS POSITION
IS ON THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
HE WAS FOR IT, AGAINST IT AROUND
SLIGHTLY FOR IT.
SHE ENDORSED IT.
ENDORSED IT.
HAD A 4 TRILLION-DOLLAR TAX
INCREASE.
AND ANOTHER $3 TRILLION FOR
THAT.
THAT IS A SOCIALIST, PETE.
THAT IS A TRUAX ABSOLUTE
SOCIALIST.
AND THEN --
JEDEDIAH: RUDY, I’M JUST
CURIOUS, JUST CURE DISCUSS, I
DON’T WANT TO INTERRUPT, I DON’T
WANT TO RUN OUT OF TIME, HAVE
YOU SPOKEN TO PENCE AT ALL ABOUT
DEBATE STRATEGY AS HE HEADS INTO
THIS?
COVID-19 WILL BE FRONT AND
CENTER ISSUE AT THIS DEBATE
FRONT AND CENTER.
I’M CURIOUS IF YOU HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT STRATEGY,
HOW TO APPROACH THE ISSUE IN
GENERAL?
>> DIFFERENT TEAM IS PREPARING
HIM.
I HAVE TALKED TO HIM HERE AND
THERE, BUT NOT LIKE IN A FORMAL
SENSE.
GIVEN THE WAY HE PERFORMED LAST
TIME, KNOWING HIM AS WELL AS I
DO, THERE IS NO REASON FOR
HIM -- PEOPLE DOING IT, BOTH HE
AND THE PRESIDENT, THEY DON’T
PREPARE LIKE REHEARSED WAY.
THEY PREPARE FOR QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS.
HERE IS THE ANSWER.
DID I GET ALL THE FACTS IN.
HERE ARE A FEW MORE FACTS,
BETTER SAY IT THIS WAY.
MUCH MORE BETTER WAY TO
PREPARED, THAN ACTING OUT OF
DEBATE.
I THINK IT WORKED WELL FOR THE
PRESIDENT EACH TIME.
PETE: UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE TO
LEAVE ITRIGHT THERE I COULD
LISTEN, TALK TO YOU ALL MORNING
LONG.
TALKING ABOUT TAKING ON THE BIG
GUYS.
>> AND HIM.
PETE: AMEN.
ABSOLUTELY WILL.
>> THESE GUYS ARE NOTHING
COMPARED TO THE MOB.